okay so now we come then to the
lationship between faith faiths and
broad sphere of economy and as you see
this is you recall from our outline we
have kind of overarching high helicopter
view of market economy as economies or
economy as a whole then central player
within that market corporation and then
finally the impact of economic activity
upon the weakest upon those who are
impoverished in the world today then
faith and values that shape the market
and basically where I see these as I was
reading materials for this session as
well as reading stuff that we assign for
the previous session it seemed to me
that that we are concerned with a kind
of two sets of issues one set of issues
are moral convictions and religious
convictions that kind of underpin the
functioning of the market and the other
sets of issues are moral and religious
convictions that somehow concerns the
goal of economic activity of markets as
a whole and these two issues are
obviously related but they're distinct
issues and that's what I want to elevate
for you these two sets of issues so
first moral underpinnings of of the
market max vapor this is a classical
text that you have been reading role of
protestantism be the rise of capitalism
and his point is that certain doctrinal
convictions the certain conditions about
the nature of the Christian faith in
this particular case belief in this
strange doctrine of predestination right
that God from all eternity has chosen
some and rejected others but you don't
know who that is really so that that
conviction have shaped profoundly
stances toward life
of the people who embrace that faith
first it was connected with engaging in
secular occupations in response to God's
calling religion wasn't something that
was sequestered from the everyday world
but rather was something that was lived
out in the sickle arity of the world and
it pushed and notched folks to kind of
systematic heli order the moral life as
a whole right that's this thesis of
favors about rationalization in this
particular case rationalization of moral
life and more life as a whole right no
life is lived on a trajectory in that
whole life as such is being led morally
in rational way and then viewing success
in those worldly occupations as a sign
of God's grace now as I was reading
materials or not on this especially the
text by Walter Russell Meade God and
gold which is very interesting
interesting piece of writing it's it's
worth worth reading now he puts this
this idea of the connection between
success in occupations and the kind of
indicator of God's grace in the
following way a better mousetrap would
not only lead the world to beat a path
to your door to build one was a sign
that God has chosen you for salvation
now when you put it that way it kind of
sounds absurd I think and maybe that's
an important way to put it right in so
crassly connected with one particular
invention right in this case and and
think in terms of the relationship
between the two whether we think it's
same absurd or convincing this is the
this is the belief that was being being
held and it had profound impact upon
one's activity in the world now all
these things the thesis Mario vapors
theses are conducive to economic growth
and certainly Protestantism isn't wasn't
the only version of such faith the
Judaism often is named as another but
nonetheless it was very very important
very important than the crit
period now there are possible critiques
of this one milder form of critique is
that religions attitudes weren't the
only significant ones that seems like an
obvious one or a tougher kind of
critique more challenging critique is
the critique that mark Knox vapor
confuses cause and effect and basically
that will come something from a Marxian
perspective right where the where the
type of convictions the Puritans
embraced were actually ideational
cultural effects of the emerging
capitalism this is what the emerging
capitalism needed in order to be able to
function therefore it created in the
form of calvin's institutes and so forth
that's that's again very crassly put but
you can put Marxian thesis in that that
way there has been work on these issues
number of folks have tried to establish
empirical evidence for that I don't want
to bore you with pluses and minuses for
it but it's a life thesis that continues
today now we haven't done much reading
for this session but it's I think it's a
very important reading that a very
important extension of babers thesis is
the following now vapor has concentrated
on individuals right the individual
state of mind and relationship to the
world and two individuals activity
increasingly I think people today are
extending vapors theses to think in
terms of social relations and speak
about social capital right social
capital is the ability is defined as the
ability of people to work together for
common purposes in groups and
organizations and then the question
becomes of the influence and importance
of social capital for the successful
performance of broad economies as well
as of individual corporations and some
of the folks in particularly Francis
Fukuyama
are you familiar with that name he's
written a big book by the name simply
trust right that poky has argued in that
book for instance that a nation's
well-being as well as its ability to
compete is called conditioned by a
single pervasive cultural characteristic
the level of trust inherent in that
society now that takes the same type of
these is that vapor advocates namely
cultural influence upon markets but
extends it to rather that applies it to
a different set of cultural
characteristics not so much individual
though those are not excluded but those
that define relationship between between
folks and one can then argue and it has
been argued that the good deal of social
capital is actually generated by
religious communities some some
estimates suggest that even 75% of
cultural capital is de facto generated
by religious communities now the fact
that if that's true that statistic is
correct right it doesn't mean
necessarily that it can't be generated
by other sources it just means that de
facto in the world in which we inhabit
that's how it is being generated there
too then religious traditions become I
think important so this is the first
part namely religions that faith and
values in conjunction with the
functioning of internal functioning of
the markets now the second point is the
purposes of the market you can put it in
those ways so so far our concern has
been relation between religious beliefs
and effective functioning of market
economy and you may say well maybe there
is a positive correlation between the
two but how important it is for there to
be a positive correlation between the
two and certainly you may not you you
might not want to say that religion is
so to say effective or matter
in the sphere of economic activity only
if it stimulates or helps economic
growth it may be effective if it does
otherwise and it depends on your
valuation of economic growth whether you
would say this is a positive or a
negative thing so but that raises the
question why and in what ways is
economic performance and is economic
growth important and I think that is a
big question that great philosophies
great religious traditions indeed i
think the humanist tradition also
consistently needs to press and ask of
of this whole sphere of economic
activity is economic growth itself the
ultimate good so to say well that's
maximizing of profit maybe not burning
the most money money may be a way of
keeping score right as they say in Texas
apparently I haven't heard it quite
except as reported or the one with more
toys wins but presumably you know and
there's one line that comes also from
from from Meade and he puts it this way
he's got this interesting way of
opportunities but Beatrice was to Dante
business has been for millions English
millions English speakers so it's a kind
of Enchantment with the point of this is
making is actually profound it's not
another crass money-grabbing right think
but rather that there is there's a kind
of a profound love that's being
displayed there some people might say
may be misplaced love but nonetheless it
is a profound log so the question is is
is kind of the economic growth itself
the goal or are broader human goals to
be achieved
well functioning inefficient market
economies and I take it that most people
would suggest that there are broader
broader goals that need to be pursued
and it's important than for us to ask
what these goals might be how we may
think about those those those goals so
for the most part capitalism has been
seen as part of a larger narrative about
the meaning of human life and of history
so one way to look at it and there are
multiple ways to look at it and what I
will say here is relatively simple but
one way to look at it is increasing
pleasure and decreasing pain in form of
satisfying the necessities and improving
the conveniences of life and you have
necessities and convenience is kind of
couplet if you read Adam Smith as I have
read just about every word from Adam
Smith because i wrote my doctoral
dissertation on Karl Marx's concept of
labor that's what's going to circuit
doctoral dissertation and of course in
order to understand Karl Marx you had to
read all sorts of stuff to which he was
responding Adam Smith of course being
being one of those folks and if you read
that that whole literature you see these
necessities and conveniences of life as
almost like a constant kind of
justification for economic activity in
that case then human beings are
conceived as pleasure-seeking animals
right they for the most part 2 to build
on kind of the dis text that we read for
Pareto there for the most part want to
eat the whole chicken do you remember
that line from everywhere this yeah the
meaning of history then is in a sense of
maximization of human pleasure and then
the questions of course can be asked is
pleasure satisfaction I suppose with
desire sufficient as the goal and
religious traditions has always have
always in the readings that we've
ingredients that we have does it show up
but if you read tariq ramadan if you
read any
of Dalai Lama if you read any of the
kind of religious unit I Ramadan note
Eric Ramallah is a a very prominent
young Muslim thinker philosopher with
relatives coming from Muslim Brotherhood
himself living in Switzerland was
forbidden to enter this country but is
engaged in many issues of how to be a
Muslim in contemporary world you can
read Eric Ramadan's writings they're
always interesting and inspiring if you
read him or if you read many others they
would suggest of course it that that the
life of pursuit of pleasure is is is
empty in many ways and it's not creating
satisfactions that one might desire now
we've read also in our readings that
nobody ought to tell you what makes you
satisfied right if you want to eat the
whole chicken you eat the whole chicken
who's to tell you that you're going to
be more satisfied if you share half of
it with somebody else right we can
discuss that too and you know further I
think in some sense more profoundly is
it possible to build a whole culture on
the pleasure principle so that you can
organize a culture around the kind of
manage pursuit of pleasure thats has
been called into question significant
ways i think i mentioned one of the
first sessions even Freud who certainly
wasn't known as being the one to spoil
people's pressure pleasures even he
thought that it's impossible to have
self without normative constrains and
let alone to have culture without simply
following the pleasure principle and
then you can ask but pleasure for whom
individuals or all human beings and if
all human beings then of course human
beings cannot be just pleasure seeking
animals denies they must be also justice
seeking and
because you have to have a distribution
of the pleasures you have to have in
order to have to seek justice I think
you also have to care for the other
right to be interested in your own
rights you need to care only for
yourself but to be interested in
somebody else's rights you need to care
for that other person so immediately
York's expanding the vision of pool
human beings are from simple pleasure
seeking to just seeking and to care
practicing individuals second options
the option that comes from the religious
religious traditions very very strongly
is something like the goal is creating a
community of justice and love something
like the global common good and by the
way that's not just from the religious
traditions if you look at the history of
a secular humanism in the West this
indeed has been the guiding vision of
secular humanism some people suggest
like like Charles Taylor that it is
really taking off the kind of
transcendent reference of human beings
love of God within in the in the
tradition of Judaism Christianity and
Islam and retaining the love of neighbor
and universalizing this and making it
into a great political and economic
program so creating a community of
justice and love something like a global
common good you might then want to argue
if you come from a particular religious
traditions that human beings are created
for love a love of the self of course
but also love of others near and far
neighbors and that indeed we do gain
pleasure by having somebody else also
eat chicken and not only ourselves and
the meaning of history then its creation
of state of affairs in which all would
flourish when we can discuss about what
the flourishing might might mean but
there is a kind of concern from the
global common good and from some of your
readings that's in significant element
of those those readings that there is a
this sense of concern for
common global common good and market
economy is a tool maybe the best tool in
the service of this end which means also
that it must be evaluated against the
backdrop of that of that end but it's
not so to say self Coralie
self-contained right so you just let it
run but rather it's inserted into that
larger narrative and that larger excuse
me that larger narrative then is
questioning the functioning of the
economy with regard to achieve mean
achieving those goals so an issue in the
nexus of questions about value market in
faith is not just does faith promote or
hinder economic growth but does economic
growth serve human flourishing and the
global common good these two questions
are fundamental as we discuss these
issues